There is someone in our VFFs today
who is all about the good and taking care of people.
Our VFF Ricky Smith was-
Hey, hey, hey!
Oh, hi, Ricky!
Ricky!
Yo!
Wait, can we be friends?
Oh, I'm usually the one asking that.
Can we stay in touch?
Can we be friends?
Yes, Ricky, yes!
Okay!
'Cause I like to dance.
I know you're a dancer.
I like to dance.
That's like my thing, I'm a dance guy.
So energy.
Oh, Ricky.
I love everything about you.
And now this new information about friendship and dancing.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, so I was so excited to talk to you today
because your organization
called Random Acts of Kindness Everywhere,
and I do love the everywhere
Yep.
because it feels blanketed and ubiquitous,
like it's possible all around
rather than this.
Ambiguous?
Yes, ubiquitous, everywhere.
Okay, gotta write down.
I know, it's like I didn't go to school,
so I studied the dictionary 'cause it's available and free.
And, but that's what you're doing
is sometimes, you know, things feel very targeted,
and where we see good,
we wonder about the rest of the world,
and how that's gonna get taken care of.
So I do think everywhere is a powerful word
to attach to the random acts of kindness.
And it feels very hopeful and very actionable.
And I just want to know what was your inspiration
behind starting your movement?
Yeah, yeah.
So it's funny that you started off
with the whole friendship thing.
I was down and out.
I moved to LA, was going through a pretty rough divorce,
and no one knew I was struggling emotionally,
mentally, financially, and I had 20 bucks left in my name.
And I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna just go back to Cleveland, Ohio where I'm from
and just try to figure things out.
And I said, you know what?
I'm gonna take this 20 bucks.
I want to buy pizza for homeless people.
I went and bought four pizzas.
And with their permission, we sat down,
and you know, I didn't talk about their homelessness.
I didn't talk about their struggles.
They didn't talk about my struggles.
And we just simply just bonded just eating pizza.
I joked that you can't eat pizza mad.
Like who eats pizza upset?
And I posted it with their permission,
having a pizza party with my friends,
and it kind of went viral.
People started doing in other cities that same day.
And I was like, you know what?
This energy and this good feeling, I got to keep it going.
It's been eight years of me just being the guy
that just tried to bring little happiness to the world.
And it's working!
Like your tentacles are reaching out and enveloping people.
I mean, that is the response.
Like when you throw these pizza parties,
it inspires other people to do it.
Have you been surprised by that, or?
Yeah, I haven't, to be honest with you.
It's just the energy to me
is like the feeling you get,
and you said it best, during these times,
literally like we're all in this together
and we're all going through something.
It rings more now true than ever
'cause we literally are going through something.
So who doesn't want to be surprised
with a free pizza, right?
Or just a pizza or a community,
'cause we're all in this together.
So I tell people all the time that,
you know, instead of taking 20 selfies, take 19.
But if you show yourself doing good,
you might think is bragging,
but it motivates, inspires other people.
I'm literally talking to my new best friend
by way of social media.
So it's like that energy, that spirit,
because people don't realize too,
it's not just the person receiving it,
you also feel good doing it.
It just makes you feel like you're connected.
People think of charity as being this thing,
you have to be rich, you have to be famous.
Nah, like you can literally just do
what you want to do in your corner, your area,
whatever, to try to make the world a better place.
I also think people are sometimes a little overwhelmed
by all that there is to do in the world.
And so when they see something that is doable
or the idea and light bulb
or the place to go to do something doable,
you've created that.
And there's a, you know,
a familiar non-overwhelming approach to what you're doing.
And yet it is huge and powerful
and we just love what you are doing.
And we wanted to help you spread that love
in your community and kindness.
So we actually reached out to our friends
of Angelo's of Lakewood,
and they're gonna give you free pizza for an entire year
to help with your homeless pizza parties.
Whoa!
(audience clapping)
And now that we are new best friends,
I'm gonna put this on my website at the show,
at thedrewbarrymoreshow.com,
I'm gonna put it on my Instagram,
and we're gonna do everything we can to help facilitate,
bring awareness and shine a light
on what you are already doing.
Thank you, Ricky.
Thank you so much.
No, thank you.
Honestly, thank you from the bottom of my heart.
My supporters, my followers are all huge fans.
So shout out to them nationwide.
They literally love you more than you know.
You are a part of Rick.
Right next to (indistinct).
So welcome to the crew.
Thank you.
I'm honored to be a part of it
and I can't wait to promote it and support.
Thank you, Ricky.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)